[Música]
muchísimas gracias
recuerdo justamente en este momento mi
charla con don antonio el profesor de mi
colegio de barbastro que tenía que
orientarnos antes de entrar a la
universidad
han pasado muchos años pero recuerdo muy
bien esa charla porque yo le dije a don
antonio que quería ser periodista y él
me lo desaconsejó rotundamente eres
demasiado tímida para ser periodista me
dijo deseo y esa recomendación y sería
adelante en mis primeras prácticas
descubrí que había bastantes tímidos
infiltrados en la redacción aprendí
enseguida que la timidez no es algo
insuperable y que solo los cínicos no
sirven para este oficio como dice el
maestro kapucinski cualquier otra
persona que quiera contar lo que sucede
a su alrededor y que lo quiera hacer con
veracidad y con rigor sea tímida o sea
descarada sirve
si hubiera hecho caso a don antonio hoy
no estaría aquí hablando de periodismo
una profesión apasionante que vive
tiempos de ruido y de dificultad una
profesión imprescindible para garantizar
el derecho a la información de los
ciudadanos una profesión que exige
independencia pero no neutralidad como
dice fernando de yarza presidente del
grupo en eo y de la asociación mundial
de editores de periódicos nunca
neutrales en la defensa de los valores
democráticos de la protección de los más
débiles y de los derechos humanos
en esa primera redacción a la que
conseguí llegar había mucho ruido el
ruido de las máquinas de escribir el
ruido de los teléfonos de mesa el ruido
de los teletipos que anunciaban con las
campanillas las noticias había mucho
humo nubes sin nubes de humo de los
cigarrillos que todos los periodistas
fumábamos había muy pocas mujeres y
había una pregunta flotando en el
ambiente servíamos las mujeres para este
oficio
mejor dicho servíamos para todo el
oficio para los consejos de redacción
para la política para la economía o era
mejor reservar nos para el
entretenimiento para la sanidad para
elegir los regalos de boda y de
jubilación
cuando me encargaron dirigir la sección
de información local uno de mis jefes
creyó elogiar me diciendo de mí que
tenía cerebro de hombre
mejor por fortuna las redacciones se han
llenado de mujeres que ponen todo su
cerebro al servicio de todos los temas
es verdad que faltan más mujeres en los
consejos de redacción que a veces se nos
escucha a la segunda o incluso a la
tercera vuelta y que seguimos hablando
de regalos claro
pero cayó el mito de que había que tener
cerebro de hombre para hacer periodismo
se trata de inteligencia no de hormonas
claro que los mitos tienen una capacidad
ilimitada para reinventarse y para
regenerarse hoy les quiero hablar de
cinco de ellos que afectan de un modo
especial a la profesión periodística
el primero de ellos es que más
información equivale a mejor información
es cierto que disponemos de una cantidad
de información nunca vista hasta ahora
en la historia pero significa realmente
que somos la generación mejor informada
de la historia
en esa redacción a la que llegue los
corresponsales locales mandaban sus
crónicas por autobús y tardaban horas en
hacerlas llegar un corresponsal de
guerra podía pasar días incomunicados
sin poder enviar su información
hoy la información fluye incesantemente
a través del universo sin límites de la
web las redacciones se han vuelto
silenciosas pero en ese silencio retumba
un ruido que no percibe el oído pero que
atruenan el cerebro es el ruido de las
noticias falsas y han existido siempre
desde que el mundo es mundo pero en
estos momentos las redes y la capacidad
de anonimato que propician las hace
prácticamente incontrolables
cuando hay una inundación sabemos que lo
primero que falta es el agua potable
potabilizar la información despejar el
ruido organizar el caos es la tarea
irrenunciable del periodista
el segundo mito es que las redes son los
medios
no sé cuántos de ustedes ojalá que
muchos han comprado hoy un periódico han
consultado las ediciones digitales o han
tenido en las manos un diario como 20
minutos pero seguro que todos hemos
echado mano de nuestro teléfono móvil
para consultar cualquiera de las redes
sociales a las que nos dan acceso
buena parte de los mensajes que circulan
por ellas son comunicación no periodismo
periodismo es como reza el lema del 'new
york times' lo que merece ser publicado
y no merece ser publicado las
intoxicaciones los bulos las noticias
falsas que como bien sabemos hoy pueden
interferir decisivamente en procesos
como el break sheet o como en unas
elecciones
el tercer mito es que la información es
gratis
ya dijo machado que todo necio tiende a
confundir valor y precio que podamos
acceder de manera gratuita a los
contenidos informativos no quiere decir
que conseguir esa información no haya
sido muy costosa aunque aprovecho para
decirles que lo será menos si todos
estamos dispuestos a colaborar de una o
de otra manera es la información que
permite generar opinión rigurosa y
fundada internet ha cambiado el modelo
de negocio y en ese nuevo escenario a
todos nos interesa saber que la mentira
tiende a estar muy bien subvencionada y
la verdad no debería jugar en desventaja
el cuarto mito es también un reproche
que todo periodista debemos escuchar una
y otra vez en una reunión de amigos o de
familiares al final de una charla como
esta los medios nos dicen solo dais
malas noticias yo respondo rotundamente
que no los medios nos situamos en
portada noticias truculentas o historias
dramáticas para vender o por morbo
aunque sirvieran para vender no lo
haríamos por eso
los medios reflejamos la realidad para
transformarla para mejor
somos espejos pero no espejos
deformantes la mayoría de las veces
creanme una mala noticia se convierte en
una buena noticia la denuncia funciona
avances contra la corrupción contra las
deficiencias en servicios públicos
contra la crisis climática contra la
violencia machista contra la
discriminación negativa por cualquier
causa que se nos pueda ocurrir no serían
tan contundentes y tan rápidos sin el
compromiso y el impulso de los medios
el quinto y último mito es que el
algoritmo puede sustituir al periodista
es verdad que ya hay robots que cruzando
datos fabrican noticias de bolsa de
deportes del tiempo pero de verdad
creemos seguro confiar toda la
información de calado solo a una máquina
el sueño de los populismos es imponer lo
que ellos llaman sus hechos alternativos
supeditar la verdad a sus intereses de
allí la importancia de que los
periodistas cumplamos nuestra labor de
conocer de comprender de confirmar de
contextualizar y de contar eso que iñaki
gabilondo llama las 5 ces del periodismo
de allí la importancia de que seamos
humildes y rápidos a la hora de enmendar
y rectificar nuestros errores y muy
firmes a la hora de mantener los valores
en nuestra profesión
termino y terminó con una historia de
esperanza en 1908 la ciudad de zaragoza
conmemora el primer centenario de los
sitios un episodio dramático de la
guerra de la independencia' frente a
napoleón españa y francia- quisieron
conmemorar lo hermanadas con un mensaje
de progreso y de esperanza el periódico
heraldo de aragón estreno para la
ocasión la rotativa más moderna que
había en el mercado e invitó a escribir
a las firmas más destacadas de la época
una de esas firmas era la de ramiro de
maeztu el intelectual de la generación
del 98
ramiro de maeztu escribió un texto para
el heraldo perfectamente extrapolable
desde la era del plomo a nuestra era de
internet dirigido a hombres ya mujeres
válido para personas tímidas y para
personas descaradas
enorgullece os de la máquina camaradas
del heraldo escribió ramiro de maeztu
pero no olvidéis nunca el cerebro el
corazón y las manos del periodista que
son el impulso que hace mover esa
máquina muchas gracias
[Aplausos]